oh yeah Max Keiser this is the COS
report Wow topsy-turvy dumb in interest
rates and Pamela Anderson knows more
about economics and well-known economics
editor Stacy yes I do want to say
there's been a momentous thing that's
happened this week and the yield curve
has inverted we're not going to go into
it in this episode but it's important to
note that that often signals our
recession is about to come it became
before the last two big recessions and
collapses and we also did see the g20
we're gonna get to that in the next
episode it's all about he said I Trump
she said obviously the head of China so
we're gonna however look at a theme that
we've been talking about and this is the
Cantillon effect all the money printing
and the inequality rising around the
world and the neoliberal economics
causing unrest global insurrection
against banker occupation this week
pamela anderson stunned the world with a
series of tweets about what she was
observing from the ground in france and
she said I despise violence but what is
the violence of all of these people and
burned luxurious cars compared to the
structural violence of the French and
global elites
structural violence of the global elites
she must be referring to neoliberal
money-printing practices that don't
create immediate violent impact but it's
more of a deferred violence you know all
these bank executives get deferred
prosecution as well as deferred bonuses
and now we have deferred violence the
violence is deferred so they create as
the protesters and France were saying
their purchasing power has diminished
because all this money printing that's
going on and you mentioned the Cantillon
effect that money printing enriches the
people on Avenue folks in Paris and
Sean's alizée in Paris and those people
who are working doing blue-collar jobs
their purchasing power is eroded and so
they have according to Pamela Anderson
figured out that this is a
actually violence system that they need
to address with quid pro quo violence
for violence yes the the violence of the
Cantillon effect is that all that free
money we've printed and we've printed
trillions from the ECB the Bank of Japan
the United States Federal Reserve Bank
the Bank of England they've printed
loads and loads and loads of money
giving it to bankers who then get free
money with unencumbered by the toxic you
know inflation so they get it free their
living standard it increases at the
expense of those further down the chain
of the money supply getting down to them
laden with all sorts of debts and an
inflation and interest rates so that's
where the violence comes I actually did
see that there somebody tweeted some of
the graffiti that was painted and tagged
on the Arc de Triomphe it said something
along the lines of we have beheaded our
leaders for less than this for you know
less than just inflation well you got a
lot of friends you know they whether the
Enlightenment was really embodied and
they had a very robust reaction to
monarchy in France and beheaded some
Kings and then engaged in the reign of
terror invented the guillotine as a way
to race through thousands of Tufts or
aristocrats beheadings right there in
plastic on cord and they have that
memory fresh and when leaders need to
speak get spoken to in a serious way
they know what to do and then she has
another important question we're
providing some of the answers so far in
these first few minutes here but she
asked instead of being hypnotized by the
burning images we have to pose the
question where did it come from
so of course most people are hypnotized
by the images by the basically the
images of the consequences of the
symptoms of something larger Donald
Trump is one of those symptoms of
something larger people are mesmerized
and hypnotized by him MSNBC can't stop
talking about him these sort of things
these images hypnotize
so we that we never asked the questions
of why why are people rising up like
this what is it about neoliberal
economics why did it why did why are the
voters whether it's in England or France
or Brazil or Mexico or the United States
why are they why do they keep rejecting
leader after leader why they why is it
getting more and more the velocity of
rejection of the established political
parties would is going on and one thing
that has happened over the last thirty
years is the introduction of
neoliberalism since Reagan since
Thatcher and we're seeing that the react
the violent reaction that you're seeing
is delayed from the cause which is a
long you know decades long on economic
injustice it is economic injustice a lot
of free money and a lot of free assets
state assets state services like the NHS
like prison systems like the military
industrial complex they're all being
handed to you know the élysée the
friends of the neoliberal elites of the
friends of political power they're
getting those contracts to run these
services for our population and running
away with all the you know the grapes
right pamela anderson addressing a
structural economic violence of this
deferred inflation lag that people
eventually catch up with and then have a
violent reaction to and you mentioned
privatization schemes there which of
course is another way to transfer the
assets that were built and paid for via
taxes by the population to a Ron T a
class of Friends of the central bankers
and unless you're going to allow folks
who help build those assets whether it's
roads hospitals schools a piece of the
action when it's transferred to the
private sector then that's outright
theft that's that's that is that is
financial violence structural financial
violence and you know this is
unfortunately not going to end anytime
soon because as we say on this show many
times you can't tape
so if they try to rectify this central
bank violence in any in any significant
way then that would that would cause a
replay of the global financial crisis
which was at that time a reckoning
trying to match the the books a little
bit there to match the risk and reward
but that was not allowed to happen they
injected another fifteen or sixteen
trillion dollars but they just gapped
the the imbalances family Anderson is
pointing to their even wider and now
it's gotten to the point where people
are saying we don't believe you anymore
we're just gonna torch these cars we're
gonna riot we're gonna act out in this
way and in France of course you know
it's the mother of all revolutions and
it's leading the way so I also want to
point out that you know there are things
we need to do as a society and part of
this the riots in France started with
the tax that has now been rolled back on
the gasoline in order to deal with
climate change but one thing that it
happened with that is because the elite
because the neoliberal elite are
basically stateless they're they're
beyond any nation state the the petty
little stuff of a nation-state and you
know is beyond what Leona Helmsley here
of New York had said about it's just the
only the little people pay taxes only
the little people are in fact subject to
any nation state laws at this point so
the burden of many of the things we need
whether it's war you know who goes to
fight all those Wars
who's the one who are the who are there
Americans dying in Iraq and Afghanistan
they tend to be from Pennsylvania or
Michigan or form you know working-class
states who are the ones that have to pay
for the disaster of climate change it's
the poor it's the people stuck out in
the rural areas and things like that so
there is an economic injustice in that
sort of terms as well and the trend is
not going to reverse anytime soon so
that's why we have talked about the
global insurrection against Bangkok
for the last ten years or more and is
gathering pace you know I'm thinking
about Cairo and the revolution that
happened there was also result of
purchasing power collapsing and the
food as a percentage of household
expenditure went up passed that magical
60 percent threshold that almost all was
throughout history triggers of
revolution so then I want to turn to
Paul Mason former economics editor of
the BBC and very left-wing and now he's
looking at what happened in Spain this
past weekend and that was in the end
Ellucian reason they basically voters
elected to many seats this party called
Vox which is far-right and he says
Spain's far right turn shows the left
needs a new strategy to defeat fascism
since the 1980s two generations to the
left have believed that the main enemy
of social justice is the neoliberal
elite today we have to accept that is no
longer true the main enemy of social
justice is people who would drown
refugees who are slandering Muslims as
pedophiles and who would as just for
starters in their war on feminism
criminalize abortion so he's saying that
we need social justice forget about
economic justice I said to him that you
need economic justice first this is
about economic justice fascism he
actually says in his article that
basically just ten percent of the
population is always fascists and
they're fascists and bla bla bla but my
thought on this and I've brought this up
before you have to look up a study
called monkeys reject unequal pay by
Sarah Brosnan and France the wall and
the fascism in that moment comes with
the economic injustice so that the study
shows you give the monkey a cucumber
them cucumber is pleases the monkey the
monkey eats it
but then the neighboring monkey gets a
grape which is much better okay we all
agree and when that monkey the first
monkey who got the cucumber sees that
they go ballistic and they resort to
violence they start throwing the
cucumbers like nothing satisfies them
and they get really tough and I think
that's what we're seeing at this moment
is that we're seeing that a certain
select group of people are privileged by
the the politicians and the central
banks they're given grapes and we we
keep on being too
like aren't you happy with brioche ie
the cucumber
it shouldn't isn't this good enough Paul
Masson it's amazing to me because he's
saying the left is failing so they need
to go toward the center yes and embrace
neoliberalism and of course you've had
that experiment
it's called Tony Blair and Bill Clinton
and it was called a third way and what
we have seen is that they once you take
that step toward neoliberalism you
become neoliberal there is no happy
medium there's no third way there's only
really neoliberalism and in this market
environment and the penitentiary right
those are the two choices for people and
the other thing about Paul Mason is that
he's saying that the left has no other
alternative because the left have two
schools of economics to draw from
Marxism Keynesianism okay with the left
needs to embrace if they want to truly
is restore social justice is to embrace
the concept of hard money only through
hard money can the left be at power
pursue with the right you need to have
hard money in the economy that's the
problem is that neoliberals have access
to infinite debt and everybody else is
has limited credit Goldman Sachs you can
borrow money at 0% and job a get done
it's just try to card ed 1718 percent or
higher and payday loans 2,000 percent
right so there's that interest rate
apartheid so lefties need to embrace
hard money if they want social justice
we're gonna take a break we'll be back
after this break
[Music]
welcome back to the constant report I'm
Max Keiser time now to turn to Caitlin
long 22-year veteran of Wall Street who
is now leading a leading voice in the
world of cryptocurrency we're gonna do
two segments of Kate the first is about
what's happening in Wyoming but first
Caitlin how did you get into this whole
crazy Bitcoin thing as a Wall Street
person I discovered Bitcoin in 2012 grew
up in Wyoming born and raised
undergraduate there then ended up on
Wall Street and discovered Bitcoin
through libertarian circles Austrian
school economic circles in 2012 so what
was the mean there's a lot of different
pieces to the Bitcoin you know incentive
model if you will what was it that
really drew your attention to it that
the penny dropped you're like aha well
this is money with no counterparty risk
and all fiat currencies have
counterparty risk so I immediately
understood that but it wasn't until a
little bit later that I understood that
this is a superior settlement system for
settling financial transactions and
actually would solve a lot of the
problems that that plagued the existing
financial system that make it frankly
unfair to mom-and-pop investors and
unstable all right so solves a lot of
Wall Street problems how come Wall
Street's so against it why is Jamie
Dimon so vociferous Lee against it I
mean it solves problems well that's a
good question and in fact actually if
you look under the hood they're not
really that against it at least at least
certain certain folks are Wall Street's
not not unified in its view clearly
you've got fidelity and backed which is
part of a sister company to the New York
Stock Exchange that are getting into it
and a number of hedge funds got into it
pretty early and and it's the old
traditional investment banks with the
exception of Goldman Sachs that are that
are generally not moving very quickly on
it okay well I'll get to back in a
moment but let's talk about Wyoming
because you're a big part of team who
helped pass the probe Bitcoin bills and
legislation in Wyoming what exactly has
passed in 2018
what could pass into law very soon there
were five bills that passed and were
signed by the governor in March of this
year and we've got six more that are
officially so-called committee bills
they just made it through the committee
last week and essentially it's designed
to make Wyoming a haven for blockchain
technology
we've we've clarified the money
transmission laws we clarified there's
no tax on cryptocurrency in fact
actually Y only has no income tax anyway
and very very low taxes sales taxes
property taxes etc but but we clarified
that there is no tax on cryptocurrency
in terms of property tax so that was one
of the bills we had we also were the
first elected body in the world that I
that identified that utility tokens were
not necessarily securities as long as
they meet specified criteria in Wyoming
those bills are already law and now
we're we're aiming to solidify the lead
that Wyoming has by solving some real
problems a couple of the big ones are
people in in this industry are
considered a high-risk ol industry is
considered a high-risk industry by the
FDIC and so the banks in general are
shunning the whole industry and that's
our signature bill for this year we we
actually had a lot of opposition to the
to the bank bill from the banking
industry last week and had a
surprisingly strong results it's not law
yet we've still got a ways to go but
this was an important hurdle to cross so
you're from Wyoming yes and you're from
Wall Street yeah and so you're kind of
like patient zero there Wyoming to get
this whole thing going and it's an
interesting match because Wyoming it is
a very independent-minded state yes and
you know Bitcoin as you point out it's a
came out of the libertarian movement etc
so it seems like a good match in a
certain way to capture the zeitgeist of
a certain ethos of individualism ISM in
America etc is that a fair statement it
is a fair statement there is a
legislature there named Tyler Lindholm
who should be on your radar screen
someone donated Bitcoin to him I think
it was in 2012 to his campaign and he's
been a big supporter it wasn't difficult
to put these pieces together I certainly
don't take credit for this there were a
lot of people for whom this touched a
nerve at the right time and it was
interesting when we got the money
transmitter bill passed last last year
that allowed the coin bases in the
circles of the world who had pulled out
of Wyoming in 2015 it allowed them to
come back into the state it was this I
believe
the son of the president of the Senate
or nephew and then also one of the
Majority Leader's in the in the house
had a son or a daughter it went in other
words it was the next generation that
was pushing the legislators to fix this
problem because as you know this is a
this is a there is a general
generational aspect to to that
blockchain technology and you know once
that ball got rolling it wasn't
difficult to put the pieces together now
there's a bit of a competition globally
to be the quote Bitcoin Switzerland you
know that people want to be puerto
rico's making it putting a stake in the
ground in malta different countries
different territories it sounds like
Wyoming I mean could it is it in that
race absolutely so okay so it could
become the destination for this industry
and how much of the industry now I mean
what are they are you getting a lot of
folks from California for example now
I'm moving into Wyoming is that is there
a culture clash well it's a good
question so far no there haven't been a
floodgate of people moving into Wyoming
I think a lot of Wyoming guides like
that just fine they don't like the
traffic in the crime and the and the
politics of folks coming from California
or Colorado necessarily but but yes
there have been some people moving there
there there have been a couple of pretty
high-profile folks Charles Hoskinson
just announced last week he's moving his
company from Hong Kong to Wyoming Don OH
yep yep let's talk about these banks for
a second so you mentioned there was a
little bit of resistance on the banking
but you know you want to do a Bitcoin
bank so what is a Bitcoin bank tell the
audience well this is a plain old base
not actually a Bitcoin Bank we're
calling it a blockchain friendly Bank
it's a plain old Bank except it's a 100
percent Reserve Bank and it's there
therefore because it's a hundred percent
Reserve Bank it won't be able to lend
but it will specifically serve this
industry this has been a problem just
basic bank accounts for for blockchain
companies have been a problem just not
even touching cryptocurrency plain old
cash I want to make that very clear this
is a plain old cash bank it's just a 100
percent reserve bank that's designed to
specialize in serving this industry and
as you know this industry of course has
higher know your customer and anti-money
laundering standards that it has to
comply with I've written in Forbes comm
I think the Bank Secrecy Act is
unconstitutional but right now it's the
law of the land
and so everybody has to comply with it
and so this industry I think has been
shunned by the banking industry for
basic cash only bank accounts precisely
because it's a higher risk industry and
and there was some powerful testimony
from the trade association the digital
asset
trade association that even they lost
their bank account even though they
weren't going to be handling
cryptocurrencies so just as Bank as a
utility just a plain vanilla bank will
Bank this industry and it has a shall
issue clause in the bill what a shall
issue clause yes we're borrowing that
from the from from firearms legislation
there's a shall issue explain that
clause in the bill that as long as the
customer meets the know your customer
and anti money laundering
requirements and as long as the bank has
capital that it shall get a bank account
from this bank oh okay so I mean it
sounds like it could be an economic boom
for a while mning so they would be like
you know the Chamber of Commerce or
whomever will be like yeah bring it on
we want the business isn't there some
full Reserve Bank of North Dakota as
well not that I'm aware of it there
might be but the full reserve banks
there are there are not very many of
them there was one that's getting
started in Connecticut that's that's
just trying to arbitrage the Fed's
monetary policy and that's not what our
bank is doing but we've been watching
that one pretty closely because the Fed
has has shunned that particular bank
there's been litigation over whether
they can get their master account we've
had great conversations through the
state of Wyoming with the Kansas City
Fed which is which is what banks Wyoming
banks and they've been open to this idea
they recognize this is an issue these
the blockchain industry is a legal
industry and yet it's been shunned on
mass by by pretty much every bank out
there in the United States and of course
in the world as well yeah well I mean is
it fair to say that this is a legacy
industry and they don't like the the
upstart they don't like this competition
they don't they are protecting their
turf it's kind of a turf battle sure and
and is that true and also what is it
about I mean you're a veteran of Wall
Street 22 year veteran of Wall Street
you see plainly the the attributes and
the benefits of this technology and yet
you've got another group legacy
economists like the Nouriel Roubini
Xanthippe all walk by norio your block
yeah okay well what are they getting
wrong about this
what were they missing I think they
they're they're Keynesian that bottom
and they and they believe that that
deficits have no consequences and that
we can continue to borrow and as long as
we're borrowing from ourselves it
doesn't matter those that's essentially
the basic Keynesian argument and of
course we all know that that's not true
at some point there will be a limit to
the amount of debt that we can continue
to pile on to the economy and this is
what's making the financial systems
unstable at bottom so sound money it's
described as the hardest money ever
invented in safety no mousses book the
Bitcoin standard nastic book
decentralized in global central banking
so you would fall into that camp that
this is hard money and this is an
economy needs to run on a sound money
basis and you can't run an economy on a
debt basis and this is gonna Chuck the
whole growth of the globe is based on
debt creation GDP is based on debt
creation so if we go back to sound money
if we measure gold or coin
yeah there's going to be winners and
losers and a lot of losers
and how do you prepare folks for that
day of reckoning what do you what's how
do you soften that message up because
it's going to be a harsh day of
reckoning when it comes
well it's interesting sayfudine and i
have had long conversations about will
it really be harsh or will it really
just be that something so much better
comes along and people naturally shift
to it we don't know the answer we can't
predict the future and and I do fear
that there is going to be a such
instability in the financial industry
that it's going to be a wild ride
that's why personally I understood from
almost the moment that that I dug into
Bitcoin really dug into it that this has
a historical significance it's it's
right up there with gold as an inflate
as a hedge against that instability in
the financial system because it's it has
no counterparty there is no one issuing
it who can default on it or who has the
ability to to just inflate its value
away by issuing more of it
yes unique once again just kind of refer
to your experience because it's
expensive and it's very high level I
mean you ran Morgan Stanley's pension
business and and now you're trying to I
guess to extend that to build a Bitcoin
related business can you talk a little
bit about that
well right now I'm purely working on
volunteer projects in my beloved native
state of Wyoming so I'm helping to
bridge this new industry which needed a
home and like you said Wyoming you know
it fit like a glove philosophically they
needed economic diversification the coal
industry of course is is on its back
unfortunately and also why only had
great building blocks there the
University of Wyoming was already
teaching about blockchain and very
importantly Wyoming invented the limited
liability company in 1977 so it was
already one of the top three states for
new business formation anyway a lot of a
lot of businesses form in Wyoming it's
got tremendous property laws for limited
liability company Delaware gets the most
of that business or gets most of it they
stole Wyoming's lead and and frankly
Wyoming would like it back and that's
what that that is this is part of the
strategy of getting it back you know
it's interesting I looked up Delaware
they are charging $250,000 to almost
2,000 of their largest registrants just
for the privilege of registering in
Delaware Frick that picked us up in a
second second if we can I'm gonna sign
off now and it will pick this up in
another segment and thank you for being
on this segment my pleasure thank you
and that's gonna do it for this edition
of the Kaiser report with me Max Keiser
Stacy herbart like to thank our guest
Caitlin long Bitcoin entrepreneur and
visionary if you want to catch us on
twitter it's Kaiser report until next
time bye all
[Music]